[Musique]
ici à Vendôme depuis 40 ans la famille
Rouillac chasse des trésors d'une valeur
inestimable je vais de ce pas à la
rencontre de Philippe et Aymeric un duo
de choc des véritables experts la maison
familiale Rouillac bas des records de
vente et il est temps pour moi d'avoir
un peu une estimation de moi-même on l'a
vu vous allez voir je voudrais
[Musique]
bienvenue merci donc les Rouillac père
et fils Philippe Aymeric pourquoi les
trois coups là c'est l'annonce théâtrale
une vente aux enchères c'est un espèce
de spectacle magnifique et ensuite les
coups qui enchaîneront ce sera des
kugaillants parce qu'il faudra passer à
la caisse après mais bon on est où ici
exactement on est à Vendôme c'est une
caverne d'Ali Baba on va retrouver des
tableaux qui viennent de toutes les
époques des casques de l'Empire perse
une paire de fesses du Bron du verre ou
des terres cuites que j'imagine qu'il
faut pas laisser tomber ça
bon alors messieurs expliquez-moi ce
qu'est le métier de commissaire-priseur
tout commence avec ça donc commissaire
priseur il y a le mot commissaire
commissaire ce sont des enquêtes tout le
monde a chez lui un objet pour lequel il
se pose une question la meilleure des
choses à faire c'est d'aller voir un
commissaire freezer on leur raconte
l'histoire de leur objet si la valeur
est intéressante alors on organise une
vente aux enchères vous avez la loupe
Philippe estime un peu mes cheveux le
grand-père des briques a vendu les
cheveux de Marie-Antoinette est-ce que
ses cheveux ont le canal médullaire
excentré toi là tu vois que tu as un
canal médullaire comme tout le monde
j'aurais quand même médullaire banal
quoi voilà et ses cheveux là il faudrait
qu'il soit vendu pour une association
caritative pourquoi on profite de
l'association moi de faire de l'argent
Philippe
t'asseoir comme ça avec autant des ans
je vais me lever finalement
de ce magnifique fauteuil le principe
c'est que tu les retournes pour
connaître leur histoire tu donnes un
coup de main papa et tu vois des marques
ici trois fleurs de lys F o n C a
fauteuil du château de Fontainebleau
pour l'empereur Napoléon 1er comment on
vous apprend pour savoir qu'il faut
retourner le fauteuil pour voir le signe
mais tu viens la rouille Academy si vous
aussi
ça c'est un petit tableau que tu as
peut-être reconnaître dis-moi je
m'appelle Olivier je suis né en 1899 et
je commence à peindre sur les bords de
la Loire alors que j'étudie
l'architecture je m'appelle je suis je
suis je suis je suis je sais pas allez
Olivier Debré ce sont des yeux de la
Loire et se projettent comme un oiseau
au-dessus de la Loire et ça c'est un
petit tableau pour pouvoir faire un plus
grand tableau ensuite
alors voilà une petite surprise Kamini
une armure alors tac le casque déjà
le bouclier
auquel on ajoute une épée une épée bon
par contre les Rouillac quand vous
vendez l'armure à l'hôtel de vente je
veux porter l'armure et faire honneur
bien sûr Academy si vous aussi vous
voulez devenir expert commissaire la
rouillette Academy je suis vraiment fan
de l'armure donc j'aimerais garder un
morceau avec c'est possible ah écoute
je vais la laisser je la laisse pas de
problème messieurs salut
[Musique]
comme demande si il nous a pas laissé
des cheveux mais si c'est ça on va les
vendre